How do you keep sensitive plot details secret?
Easy: don't give Tom Holland a script. We're
joking! In fact, he's far from the only
actor who's spoiled a huge blockbuster.
Will Smith has spent enough time in Hollywood
to know that spoiling the ending of a film
before it comes out is a surefire way
to ruin it for an audience. But in 2007,
he did just that at a news conference while
talking about his film "I Am Legend." As Smith
began rambling about the film, co-producer and
co-screenwriter Akiva Goldsman realized that
he had gone too far, and he yelled, "Don't
give away the ending!" But it was too late,
and Smith had already crossed the line.
The journalists present were instructed
not to report on the ending of the film, so
thankfully, they were able to do damage control.
Since "I Am Legend" was based on a novel of
the same name that had already been adapted
multiple times, Smith might have figured that
being loose-lipped about the details wasn't a
big deal — after all, plenty of people had
already read the book, so there weren't
really any secrets to keep, right? Well, not
quite. The screenwriters completely changed
the ending of the film, so ideally, it was
supposed to be a surprise for everyone.
With a franchise as huge as "Star Wars,"
spoilers are bound to get out every once
in a while. At the 2016 Star Wars Celebration in
London, Jiang Wen, who played Baze Malbus in the
then-upcoming "Rogue One: A Star Wars Story,"
answered a question about his own character. He
started off by saying that he couldn't say much
about his own fate, but then he proceeded to
tell everyone in attendance that Donnie Yen's
character, Chirrut Imwe, was going to die.
"And when this guy's dead, I do something better."
Luckily, panel emcee Gwendoline Christie
came to the rescue and managed to stop
Wen from giving anything else away. While
he did stick to his promise about keeping
his own character's fate a secret, he
did spoil another one. Whoops! It seems
like he was so eager to deflect the attention
from himself that he said a little too much.
In 2009, Rachel McAdams starred in the film
"The Time Traveler's Wife," which was based
on the novel of the same name. McAdams
could perhaps be forgiven for assuming
that the target audience for the adaptation
was already familiar with the book. Of course,
the plot of any film that involves time
travel will almost definitely include some
trippy twists and turns, and that was the
case with "The Time Traveler's Wife." But
those twists aren't nearly as interesting
when you know what's coming in advance.
McAdams began revealing major plot twists during
a 2009 interview with Jon
Stewart on "The Daily Show."
"He goes forward as far as his own death."
"Whoa!"
When she realized she had said too much,
she didn't try to backtrack. Instead,
it just seemed like she figured
she might as well run with it and
keep talking. Stewart joked that he
still couldn't wait to see the film,
but after watching that interview, you
really wouldn't need to buy a ticket.
"But obviously that's not the plot."
Gwyneth Paltrow has always had trouble holding
back when it comes to spoilers. Throughout her
time playing Pepper Potts in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, she has been known to let key details
slip before the premieres. Before the release
of "Avengers: Endgame," she revealed a major
detail about Tony Stark and Pepper Potts'
lives after the tragic events of "Avengers:
Infinity War"... and in doing so, she gave
away a lot more than she probably realized.
In an interview for the official
"Infinity War" magazine,
Paltrow was asked about Pepper's
relationship with Tony. She answered:
"Pepper and Tony have had a real long
journey together. She obviously starts
as his dutiful assistant, and
then the relationship evolves,
and now this decade later they're
married, and they have a child."
Endgame, 40:13, Tony puts his
hand over his mouth, "S---!"
Yeah, that last part was a big spoiler for
fans eagerly awaiting Endgame. At the time,
Pepper and Tony were a galaxy apart
following the events of Avengers:
Infinity War, and had only briefly
talked about having children.
"So you woke up and thought that we were…"
"Expecting."
"Yeah."
"Yes?"
"No."
Fans had no idea they would be reunited and would
have a child after the time-jump in "Endgame."
What's most surprising is that the official
magazine printed the quote in the first place.
Michael Keaton dropped the mother of all spoilers
while promoting Tim Burton's 1989 "Batman" film.
During an interview with David Letterman, the
two started delving into Batman's origin story
and his connection with the Joker. In the midst
of their conversation, Keaton seemingly forgot
that the audience was there for a second, because
he got a bit carried away describing the plot.
"I witness…Batman, Bruce Wayne witnesses
the murder of his parents when he's a kid."
"And the Joker had done that?"
"Yeah, but he doesn't know it 'til later.
Oh, I'm kind of blowing the plot here."
This, of course, was not an element
of existing Batman mythology,
invented as a plot twist for the '89 film.
Needless to say, this was a shock for both
Letterman and his audience. But by that point,
the damage had been done, and the audience was
probably a little disappointed. Fortunately,
the spoiler clearly didn't affect the success
of the film, which went on to make $411 million
worldwide, revitalize the comic industry, and
help define superhero movies as we know them.
For some reason, it seems exceptionally
difficult for the casts of superhero
films to keep quiet about key plot points.
Just look at Jason Momoa's slip up on "The
Late Late Show with James Corden." While
promoting their new film "Aquaman," Momoa
and his co-star Yahya Abdul-Mateen
II made an appearance on the show,
and they let the audience in on a few
things they weren't really supposed to know.
Momoa started talking about the relationship
between their two characters
and had a slip of the tongue.
"But then there's a whole emotional scene
with his father because I kill his dad. Oop!"
Momoa went on to joke that this is why he always
has Abdul-Mateen answer the questions. Maybe
if he'd been in character as Aquaman, he'd
have been more tightlipped about the plot.
"Something something trident."
See? That's better!
The ending of "Avengers: Infinity War" was
gut-wrenching for Marvel fans. When Thanos
snapped his fingers, half of all life
in the universe disappeared. But if you
caught a particular "Good Morning America"
interview with Don Cheadle and Mark Ruffalo
that aired almost a year before the movie
came out, you might have seen it coming.
"Wait 'til you see this next one. Everybody dies."
"Dude, dude, dude."
"Not everybody….no, was that…?"
It's true that Ruffalo wasn't too specific with
this spoiler, so it didn't seem too memorable
at the time. But some fans probably did start
to suspect that depressing finale — there's
no doubt that some of them fully expected
many of the Avengers to perish. Of course,
having some time to steel yourself
emotionally might have made it easier
to accept your favorite character's demise.
So maybe we should have thanked Mark Ruffalo.
"You're marginally better than
Tom Holland, but that's it."
"I taught Tom Holland."
Tom Holland is the undisputed king of Marvel movie
spoilers. The actor has dropped so many spoilers
during interviews that at this point, it's become
a running joke. But Holland is so enthusiastic and
endearing that it's hard to feel annoyed at
him for his habit of letting spoilers slip.
Before a screening of "Avengers:
Infinity War" in Los Angeles,
Holland made an appearance and shouted: "I'm
alive!" When the audience seemed confused,
Holland's mistake slowly dawned on him
— he was under the impression that they
had just seen the film and knew his character
would die, but it hadn't started yet. Whoops!
Jiang Wen might have spoiled the fate of one
character in "Rogue One," but many years before
that, David Prowse ruined the biggest plot twist
in "Star Wars" history. When the man behind Darth
Vader's mask was interviewed about "The Empire
Strikes Back" in 1978 — two years before it was
even released — he openly shared one of the most
shocking moments in any of the "Star Wars" films.
Prowse was at a fan meet-up when
he dropped a bomb regarding Luke
Skywalker and Darth Vader's relationship, saying:
"Father can't kill son, son can't kill father."
Thankfully, his reveal was only printed in a
single local newspaper article. And clearly,
not many people read the original article,
because the vast majority of fans
were still totally caught off guard.
If you don't recognize the name Tyler
Nelson, there's a reason for that:
he put a stop to his acting career when
it had barely begun. Nelson was cast as an
extra in "Indiana Jones and the Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull," and naturally,
he was over the moon about the opportunity to be
a part of an "Indiana Jones" film. His role was
apparently to play a Russian dancing after
Indy was captured. His involvement got some
attention in his hometown, and a local newspaper
interviewed him to get the scoop on the film.
But instead of simply sticking to
the story of how he ended up on set,
he started revealing the entire plot of
the film. He might as well have handed
the reporter a script. He completely violated
his non-disclosure agreement, and as a result,
he faced some serious consequences. Once
word got back to the studio that Nelson
had blabbed, Steven Spielberg's
spokesman, Marvin Levy, commented,
"Who knows whether that particular person
will ever work in this town again?"
Nelson was promptly cut from the film,
and his mistake appears to have
cost him a future in acting.
"Spider-Man: No Way Home" features several
returning actors from prior films in the
franchise, including Tobey Maguire and
Andrew Garfield as returning Spider-Men.
"You okay?"
"It's my back. It's kind of stiff
from all the swinging I guess."
While Marvel's attempts at keeping a lid on
the film's biggest comebacks were always going
to be tough considering how many people were
involved, Alfred Molina did them no favors.
The returning Doctor Octopus actor spilled the
beans more than a year before the film's release.
The rumors started when Molina was spotted on the
set of the production, and the question came up
as to his involvement during an interview with
Variety. Assuming that published reports of his
appearance had already made it official,
the actor wasn't shy about it. He said:
"When we were shooting it, we were
all under orders not to talk about it,
because it was supposed to be some
great big secret. But, you know,
it's all over the internet. I actually described
myself as the worst kept secret in Hollywood!"
"Up here. He's up there. It's
the guy from the bridge."
A year after the film's release,
though, Molina told the Radio Times
that the studio was pretty miffed that
he'd confirmed his appearance. He said:
"Kevin Feige was on a red carpet somewhere
and someone asked him about some Marvel
movie and apparently he got a bit
snippy and turned around and said,
'Ask Alfred Molina.' So I got
into a little bit of hot water."
The "Star Wars" prequel trilogy was
among the first major movie series to
be produced in the era of internet spoilers. As
fan communities popped up in the mid-to-late '90s,
it became harder and harder to prevent plot
leaks from reaching the masses. But while
Lucasfilm surely took security seriously
to prevent spoilers, they couldn't stop
one of their own stars — Samuel L. Jackson
— from giving away his own character's fate.
Jackson played the lightsaber-wielding
warrior Mace Windu in the trilogy. He
was also one of the biggest actors involved in
the trilogy and was always being asked about
his part in the films. And in one particularly
revealing interview with Now Playing Magazine,
he talked a little bit too much when
asked about what part his character
had to play in the third prequel.
Jackson bluntly told the magazine:
"Dying! Yeah, like all of the rest of the
Jedi. I can't tell you [the specifics],
but yeah, it's an awesome death."
"So the prophecy says."
Admittedly, most fans probably
knew this was likely given the
backstory established in earlier
films, but it was a startling
admission from an otherwise tight-lipped
production and sent fans into a frenzy.
When your big blockbuster movie is based on a
well-loved and widely read comic book universe,
it might be hard to keep all of
the story a secret. The movie's
biggest plot points might be common
knowledge among comic book readers,
but that doesn't mean wider audiences know
what's coming. Such was the case for "X-Men:
Apocalypse," the third film in the relaunched
franchise. Fan favorite Peter Maximoff — aka
Quicksilver — returns from the previous film, and
one of the major twists is the revelation that
he's the son of longtime "X-Men" villain Magneto,
a fact that comic fans might've already guessed.
"Are you going to tell him?"
"Might. One day."
Unfortunately, actor Evan Peters just
couldn't keep the secret for everyone
else while talking to JoBlo about his
character's place in the film. He said:
"I have learned that [Magneto's]
my father at this point. [...] He
knows who he is now so he is trying
to find him. He's been searching for
him. It's been 10 years and he hasn't
found him and then something happens."
Ultimately, of course, "X-Men:
Apocalypse" wasn't the popular,
acclaimed blockbuster that the previous
films had been, and the spoiled revelation
wasn't something that wound up ruining the
movie. Thankfully, though, Peters remained
much more tight-lipped when it came to his
return in Marvel's "WandaVision" in 2021.
You might not expect a modest, low-budget
character drama about a man and his dog to
be the subject of a major spoiler discussion,
but here we are. Starring Channing Tatum,
the 2022 film "Dog" was inspired by the actor's
own life and a road trip he took with his dying
dog in 2018. The film doesn't include any truly
dramatic plot twists, stunning revelations,
or major mind-benders. In fact, it's a
fairly light-hearted, family-friendly tale
with a happy ending. But that's exactly why Tatum
himself gave away the ending before it released.
In a kind of "reverse spoiler," Tatum talked
about what didn't happen in the movie, and it
wasn't a mistake or slip-up. In fact, it was in
an attempt to attract more people to the film,
considering the history of animal movies like
"The Call of the Wild" and "Marley & Me" — both
were advertised as upbeat family films
and end as tearjerkers. As a result,
Tatum wanted to assure audiences that "Dog" would
not conclude with a depressing or morose ending.
"It's a good ending, so everyone
knows. See, everybody's like, "Huhh.'"
When it comes to tragic character deaths,
few can top the emotional tour de force
that audiences endure in "Logan,"
the third solo film for Wolverine,
played by Hugh Jackman. His
ninth appearance in the role,
it was highly publicized as the last time
Jackman would wield the adamantium claws,
and the rumor mill was spinning that Logan
wouldn't survive the events of the movie.
Very loosely adapted from the epic comic
book miniseries "Old Man Logan," the film
might not have killed off its hero had it stuck
closer to its source material, but in the end,
with Jackman insistent on retiring the role, it
indeed ends with the death of the title character.
"So, this is what it feels like."
But while many were expecting Logan's demise, it
most assuredly was not a certainty going into the
release of the film. That is, not until Jackman
himself decided to say it rather plainly in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly. The interview
was published the day after the film's release,
but for everyone who couldn't make it to the
premiere, it was a huge spoiler. Jackman told EW:
"As soon as I saw the script, I got it. Logan
is someone [who’s] most scared of intimacy,
and so he wants to be alone and do things
for himself. The idea that, in the end,
he must give his life to save someone
else... I thought that was really powerful."
While his casting was announced all the
way back in 2007, Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson
finally starred as the titular anti-hero in
"Black Adam" when it was released in 2022.
Though it lacked Shazam — the hero whose comic
books originally spawned Black Adam back in the
1940s — the film still has plenty of surprises.
This includes the Justice Society of America,
an iconic superhero team featuring heroes like
Doctor Fate and Hawkman. But it also included a
jaw-dropping post-credits scene that had to be
seen to be believed, as Henry Cavill reprised
his role as the Man of Steel in a sequence that
set up a future clash of titans. The only problem
was The Rock himself had already spoiled the
scene in the days leading up to the film.
While promoting the movie on the red carpet
of the film's world premiere — more than a
week before its wide release — Johnson talked
to Entertainment Weekly and decided to let
the cat out of the bag when asked about
the presence of Superman in the film.
"We've all been fighting for this moment,
so I will say this: Welcome home."
Though he didn't say it explicitly, Entertainment
Weekly knew exactly what he was saying,
and tweeted out the clip with the announcement
that Henry Cavill had returned as Superman and
was back in the DCEU. As we all know
now, of course, that didn't last.
"Star Wars: Revenge of the Sith" wasn't the last
major blockbuster movie that Samuel L. Jackson
wound up spoiling in his effort to promote his
next big flick. Nearly 15 years later in 2019,
Jackson starred in "Captain Marvel," a prequel
to the MCU set in the 1990s. In addition to
introducing cosmic hero Carol Danvers, it shed
new light on the history of Jackson's Nick Fury.
Digitally de-aged, Jackson
was a major part of the story,
which revealed Fury's first meeting with
a superhero and how he conceived of the
Avengers Initiative. But that wasn't all, and
one of the most fun revelations was spoiled
by Jackson himself — across two separate
interviews — before the movie even released.
It all started while Jackson was speaking
with Entertainment Tonight in January of
2019. He recklessly revealed that the film would
tell the story behind Fury's famous eyepatch,
but didn't elaborate on how he'd lose
it. That detail would come while he was
being interviewed for The Playlist just
days before the film landed in theaters,
though it may not have been entirely his fault.
Having seen the film ahead of its
official release, the interviewer
directly addressed how he lost the eye. Well,
Jackson went right along and talked about it,
even addressing rumors that he doesn't
like cats, an allegation he denied.
"I'm gonna give him all the
love and hugs that he need."
At the time of its rollout, one of the biggest
stars in Phase 1 of the MCU was Natalie Portman
in 2011's "Thor." The A-list actor had just won
an Oscar earlier that year and starred opposite
Chris Hemsworth as Jane Foster, a scientist
who discovers the Asgardian prince after
he's banished to Earth. But following
a bad experience on the sequel, "Thor:
The Dark World," Portman swore off working for
Marvel. Some years later, the prospect of working
with the director Taika Waititi was enough to lure
her back to the MCU for "Thor: Love & Thunder."
But in her excitement, she also spoiled a
major plot twist before the movie came out.
While it was well known thanks to trailers
that her character Jane Foster would be given
the powers of Thor, what audiences who
weren't comics readers probably didn't
see coming was that Foster is stricken with
terminal cancer, and her powers allow her to
stave off her own death. Unfortunately, Portman
went a little too far in talking about all that
while speaking with Hindustan Times while
promoting the film a month early. She said:
"She's new at it. And also keeps reverting
to human form, so there's kind of danger
always that, like, it might be her last
moment getting to experience that."
But apparently Portman realized her snafu,
because she immediately acknowledged the
cardinal sin she'd just committed and added:
"I don't know, that might be...
that might be a big spoiler, sorry."
When it was announced that Kang the Conqueror
would be the villain of the third "Ant-Man" film,
speculation went into overdrive on what the
film might be about. Paul Rudd remained cagey
on the details, but his co-star Evangeline
Lilly let the excitement of her return get
the better of her. Eager to share her prep work
on the film ahead of the movie's production,
the actor took to social media, posting
images for her legions of followers. What
they briefly saw was the front cover
of the film's screenplay, and while it
wasn't enough to reveal any of the script's
secrets, who she tagged gave the game away.
Because in addition to tagging her known co-stars,
she also curiously tagged Corey Stoll. The actor
who had co-starred in the first film in the
series as the villain Yellowjacket had not
been officially announced as a member of the
cast, and when the media got wind of her post,
the rumor mill immediately fired up. Her rushed
deletion of the post only added fuel to the fire.
As many suspected, Stoll did wind up
returning in the threequel. Thankfully,
though, Lilly never let slip that his
character had been transformed into
the comic book villain MODOK, a secret that the
studio was clearly saving for the film's release.